do you know that lindsay lohan now has a
non-fungible token
lindsay lohan who is
can i say never relevant lindsay lohan
was relevant when she was
a child right right yeah
and then i mean it's just been a
succession of rehabs
a succession of you know photos of her
collapsed on someone's lawn
and now she's selling a non-fungible
token
for what purpose other than to just bang
her fans over the head
that small group of people that think
it's funny to own a
lindsay lohan nft what is the artwork on
it what does it even look like
she's holding up a diamond the ethereum
diamond
that the crypto she loves and that's it
it's just covering her eye like does she
have
real money in crypto apparently she's
all into crypto for the past year now
her and soulja boy have been going hard
on the crypto and the nft
how much is her nft how much is a
lindsay lohan uh token
she sold this for uh 17 000 but she
donated
it all to uh save the children
but this is a tax scam she's trying to
this let's be very honest about this
this is a tax scam
and can you explain because you were
explaining it to me
how if you have these nfts and you sell
them
and by the way just because it is a scam
and i'm identifying it as such doesn't
mean
or shouldn't restrict me from getting
involved in doing it
so don't don't be one of those people or
go oh
last episode you said it was a scam in
the next episode
you're selling it to us don't be that
don't do that
now we don't have one but i'm saying if
we are if we're to give one or get one
if we're to
pump one up we might ours is not to be a
scam
theirs is a scam do you understand
lindsay lohan's a
deflating balloon we're on our way up
so if you get involved on the ground
floor what we're doing that's a good
move
but lindsay lohan i mean there's nothing
left here what's the last thing she did
laurel canyon with brett easton ellis
that guy who says uh tim can you do my
podcast in three years
and i go what he goes we have a it's a
patreon only podcast
we'd like to book you in november me and
my boyfriend are huge fans i'm like
how about because i i asked him to do my
show i'm like how about you do my show
cause it's relevant
okay what's the last thing he's written
by the way what's the last thing he's
done
freddie's tineless it's the last thing
he's done
laurel canyon with lindsay loh what she
was in that i think
yes she was she was and a porn star and
and by the way brett's done some great
stuff so we're not no shade to him
but when i ask you to be on the show say
yes don't tell me you have a patreon
only podcast you'd like me to do it
oh he he released his first piece of
nonfiction it was that one called white
it's a collection of essays on
contemporary political culture remember
it was really like yeah
who cares anyway i'm doing bffs with
dave portnoy and josh richards i'm very
excited about that
i like portnoy we make fun of the
barstool people sometimes
but i do like them a lot and i think
you're a force for good
overall in the media landscape so we'll
be doing that podcast on tuesday very
happy about that and brett east and
ellis
the offer is still on the table so if
you and your boyfriend have the time
you could come in and chat with us about
what it was like to make laurel canyon
with lindsay lohan
and uh where you think her coin is
headed
now how many lindsay lohan non-fungible
tokens are there
so far there's one there's one token for
17 grand yeah and who bought that
just some guy some guy uh his name is uh
let me let me find his name here because
because what they do is they buy it and
then someone out bids them
because so people don't buy them to own
them they buy them to then sell them for
a higher price
so they get traded all the time like
mark cuban right now is do you know mark
cuban is selling his tweets as
as ntfs i've heard that yeah or nfts
excuse me when i said this was the era
of fake business i had no idea how
correct i was i had no idea
how prescient that rant would be and how
far this would go
we're selling nothing i mean this is
literally nothing now
celebrities did what did kings of leon
do they just sold an album for 6 million
i mean this is just it seems like
from far away a bad faith attempt
to milk the last amount of remaining
money from your fan base
it seems to me like these are people
that are trying to just bang their fan
base
over the head ring the register
sell them absolute horseshit get
involved in a cultural moment
build this mania convince
people that this is going to be a thing
when they know it's not
it seems like a horrible thing to do
how would we get involved in doing it if
we wanted to
what would be the first step your agent
actually just texted me a company that
we might team up with we didn't fire him
yet
where is and what because to me
it seems why what
has kings of leon done that's worth six
million dollars
and whatever i don't i don't whatever
the kings of leon or whatever
fine yeah what's their song isn't it
you somebody oh yeah yeah
six million what is it a token which is
the kings of leon
it's the album itself like soulja boy is
selling songs
so you get an album for six million
dollars yeah so you own it but everyone
else no one else
but everyone else could listen to it but
you're the one who owns it you own it
you can do well this seems interesting
well well well well maybe maybe i was
too rash
in my condemnation of this so i own the
kings of leon album
i bought it for six million dollars i
could distribute it how i want
no well it's just available to the
public but you're the one who
tim dillon owns the king of leon so what
does
ownership mean if everyone can listen to
it i don't know
that's what my problem is i don't know
what ownership means what's the equity
in owning something
like cloud i guess
i don't understand this at all i'm
terror i'm confused
it's absolutely a tax scam this makes
bitcoin seem like the most legitimate
thing i've ever heard
it's absolutely a tax scam because you
would tell me as long as you sell one of
these
you can and and you can prove that you
know what the cost is yes you've ten of
them and this is ray cump confirmed this
is probably true
and you guys are gonna go off in the
comments probably and say we don't know
what the [ __ ] we're talking about
but if you have ten of them you sell one
for ten thousand you can then donate the
other nine
and then you can say you're at a loss of
ninety thousand because it's appraised
at ten thousand each
and then that's a tax write-off right
all goes to charity i don't know if
that's true
i don't know if that's true right [ __ ]
said it's legit so if i sold if we could
sell
a non-fungible token on this show and i
sold it to the fans
and and i let's say we get 20 000
worth and i sold one for a grand i could
write off the other 19 000. yeah
yeah and especially if you're donating
everything to charity too now you're
looking at
you know so so i can donate
the 19 000 to charity or it's also a
write-off because it's a loss
because you you could have gained is it
actual so i'm actually donating the
money to charity i'm not giving them the
token
right yes i'm not handing lindsay
lohan's not handing to save the child
she's not handing the children to the
token with her with the diamonds she's
giving them the ethereum
that was used to buy the nft which has a
cash value
correct okay and then she gets to write
it off
it's not confusing at all folks the
american economy is in great shape and i
don't want you to say it's not
i don't want you to say it's not people
are buying a lot of digital real estate
and video games too so that's another
nft
it can come in like digital is this a
way for canceled people to come back can
kevin spacey launch a coin
can harvey weinstein launch a coin can
harvey weinstein have an nft
i mean let's think about this are is
there a way for these people to get
back in the saddle through nft's
non-fungible tokens
is there a token market for people like
o.j simpson
who's really not even canceled but i
mean for people like morgan wallen who
said the n-word in his driveway
can he have a non-fungible token can he
just have an n
can morgan wallet sell a token with an n
on it and that somehow you would invest
in it and you would own the n word that
morgan wallen said
could you own could he just sell the
clip of him yelling the n-word and then
you own the end
i own morgan wallin's n-word you could
tell your friends that when you went to
dinner you say i own morgan wallen's
n-word
and you can listen to it but i own it
and they go that's cloud that's pretty
cool
is there a way to is there a way to do
something like that can you just sell
something you've said
yes you could sell just something you've
said
you own the audio version i could sell
the corporate steakhouse rant yes
i could say the tim dillon corporate
steakhouse rant is going for
16 000 and if you want to buy it you own
it now everyone could listen to it but
you own it you now own my words
so i could sell more than just pictures
i could sell audio
i could sell an album a comedy album i
could sell something like that
jiff of you just dancing cuban sold a
gif of him dancing in the dallas
mavericks jersey
i wonder if like rockefeller and
carnegie and vanderbilt came back i
wonder how disgusted they'd be at the
new crop of people
that have taken their place you know
what i mean like i i wonder like guys
that built bridges and roads and oil
refineries
would sit down and go and now what are
we doing and mark cuban goes i'm selling
this it's
me dancing and uh i mean i'm wondering
if they would be absolutely
horrified by the new crop of
business moguls that we have now elon
musk who's you know selling
nfts on mars he's selling non-fungible
tokens you can go back didn't this thing
blow up the other day
oh his spaceship yeah yeah yeah so
that's what you do as a billionaire you
just blow up spaceships while everyone
on earth crawls around without health
insurance
is that kind of the society we've set up
am i wrong we have billionaires just
blowing up spaceships in the sky
while like unemployed school teachers
just crawl around
on the floor looking for [ __ ]
painkillers
i mean is that not the world we've got
if you were an alien and you landed and
somebody explained society to you you go
yeah these guys have billions of dollars
you go well why they go where they blow
up
spaceships they take spaceships up to
the sky and
blow him up i know elon musk's smart guy
but he doesn't retweet me so i don't
give a [ __ ]
but what i'm saying is like these
non-fungible tokens we've so we've
entered into a very interesting
so now everything is currency yes is
that kind of where we're going here
everything's now i know there's a
bitcoin expert in a com in the youtube
comments because they have
they have all the time in the world
these people that are going to yell at
me and tell me i'm an idiot
but i'm admitting i'm an idiot because i
don't know about these things i'm
unaware i'm learning about them on the
fly
you see like you don't know much about
them either idiot in the comments
because
these are new things okay so i'm just
learning so
everything is currency yes and
everything can be traded
and you just gotta find a group of
people that are willing to see the value
in something
so as long as someone sees the value in
something no matter how
absurd it is mark cuban dance what is
why does that have value that mark cuban
is dancing in a gif i don't know
remember after the whole uh wall street
bets thing happened mark cuban's like
this this got people like my son to
start taking an interest in stocks
i'm like doesn't you being a billionaire
have get him to take interest in this
what
i mean it's very interesting to me
uh where does this end
how and where does this end is is this a
massive crash
it has to be i mean does this just
bottom out
lindsay lohan hasn't does anyone else
have nfts who else has an nft
soldier boy is big on that okay he's
selling uh songs called crank that
um also the neon cat guy do you remember
neon cats i do not
he was the it's the pop tart cat that
shoots rainbows that went for
477 000 it was a rare gif of the neon
cat
with the pop he's a pop-tart body and
it's a cat's head
it's like a internet
like meme um
i i mean half a million dollars yeah for
the pop-tart with the cat's hat neon cat
yeah
so that person gets to own neon cat
just one jiff and so um
those are kind of the people on the
front lines of the
nft world
could just lane maxwell started nft
there's so many platforms they'd
probably take her
like why not why shouldn't why can't she
sell an nft of of
of bill clinton [ __ ] an underage girl
and just say here this is this isn't do
you want to own
bill clinton [ __ ] an underage girl
the cia is going to have a non-fungible
token very soon by the way
the cia will just start slinging nfts
here
here is uh you now own a gif
of the cigarette girl at abu ghraib with
the leash guy
you now own that 250 000
you know why here's a gif of people uh
putting the bombs into uh building the
thermite in the buildings of 911.
here's a gif of that 380 000
proof it was an inside job just went for
380
000. i own the [ __ ] 911 nft man
wow there's just not much to say
i i would like to maybe get involved
because everyone else is getting
involved and i feel left out
and just because this is a scam and it's
not based on anything doesn't mean we
shouldn't
figure it out and participate you
understand
so next week if we have an nft i don't
want all the people that have listened
to this to start
i don't know getting angry we may have
to delete this episode i guess
next week and just claim that everyone
was experiencing it said
because our nft would be good if we had
an nft we'd link it to maybe a project
that was coming up or something i don't
know
i have a bit i i have people that i talk
to about bitcoin that might know
more about this than i do you know
i don't know i just i just think it's an
interesting development in the uh
economic cycle of our country
lindsay lohan is big into cryptocurrency
i mean does that does that not worry
anyone does that not scare anyone about
the future
of cryptocurrencies that lindsay lohan
is out there
selling it and she's i mean i don't know
man
we do what we can do